hey consider yourself invited not just
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
but also to join the discussion on the
david pakman show
subreddit at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t some uh
interesting posts on the david pakman
show subreddit this morning including
one post about listen
the first debate is just days away what
should biden's strategy be
and what will trump's strategy be now
you can read this entire post on the
subreddit but my thoughts are the
following
a joe biden needs to be aggressive joe
biden as you know has been framed as
demented tired confused
beta for lack of a better term by donald
trump while donald trump has framed
himself
as the strong powerful leader
joe biden needs to be prepared not just
on the facts
which are the facts about trump's
failure on coronavirus
the fact about how our economy has
suffered so much more than it had to and
so much more
than other economies thanks to trump's
failings on coronavirus
so biden needs to be prepared on the
facts but biden needs
a strategy where he will be aggressive
and uh donald trump you know he he did
things with hillary clinton
ominously standing behind her and
pointing to her and saying you'd be
locked up if i was president you know
all of this stuff
trump is likely to go for that again and
joe biden
needs to be prepared and i believe joe
biden needs to come out swinging
there is very little downside to it
and he needs to protect himself from
with from what trump's likely strategy
would be
trump's likely strategy is going to be
to try the same stuff that he tried on
hillary
on biden and it will be up to biden
uh whether it will work or whether it
will not work trump is likely to come
in with critiques poorly worded and
inarticulate but critiques of
the obama administration biden needs to
be prepared
to immediately rebut that and to say
this is a referendum
on these last four years do people want
you again for another four years and of
course he needs to be prepared uh uh
to actually have the the factual fight
as well
uh and joe biden needs to be prepared
for the low blows that donald trump is
likely to come in with that includes
hunter biden stuff this includes um
uh h1n1 seems to be a popular topic for
donald trump this includes
biden and china and biden needs to have
a strategy for how to deal with that so
we'll be covering it live i do think it
will be very very interesting
another post from the subreddit lyme guy
asking do any of you ever get angry
watching the trump movement
i feel like this election is not good
for mental health
uh i i agree i actually agree i am
looking forward to
hopefully the removal of trump and
things being boring for a while
it won't be good for the show
financially but i don't care about that
uh it'll be it'll be better for the
country and it'll be good
for our mental health and i completely
agree and then lastly
user morton posts to the subreddit
it will likely take two to three
elections to undo
some of the damage and i agree and
morton points out that
you know our hopes should not be too
high in terms of what a biden first term
would do
i think we need to think about it more
systemically it's not just a biden first
term
it's biden winning democrats may be
taking the senate now maybe
in 2022 and it's going to be a
cumulative effect there are things that
joe biden can relatively quickly undo by
executive order
there is damage like including damage to
the climate damage to
international alliances which have been
ruined under donald trump
that will take some time and then
remember on the tail end of it we're
still going to have 60 million trumpists
living in the united states
what do we do about that i still don't
have the answer
join the discussion as more than 23 000
of you already have at davidpakman.com
reddit one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you
five dollars when you sign up for their
completely free
service at privacy.com pacman i've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even auto
fill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because
you can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a 10 a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com pacman